[music]
we are here to show our solidarity with
the ukrainians
a peaceful people who
have been fighting for their independence since
2014 we must not forget that we are
already at war with russia which is
always being explained away we
lost 13,000 of our people there so and so
we as europeans should show that we support
this country in its fight
for independence and for
democracy that means we need
sensible vests we need
night vision goggles the german
federal government can help with that they
are not weapons in that sense on the
other side we cannot
fight tanks with slingshots we
won't attack russia as
ukraine we want to defend our country
logically there are
only losers if there's a war
in russia and so emphasizes
but we can't influence that
[music]
o